[Musique]
et
quel richissime producteur pour quel
metteur en scène d'hollywood a planté
ses décors recréer ces personnages pour
qu'elles reconstitution d'un passé
révolu
ce ne sont pourtant pas des personnages
de cinéma mieux même il leur est
interdit d'être filmés ou photographiés
et la plupart des images que vous allez
voir on était en quelque sorte volé
souvent au téléobjectif c'est à dire de
très loin
[Musique]
un dimanche sur deux ils se réunissent
entre eux dans la maison de l'un d'eux
qu'il vient pour un jour à la fois
église et centre de la communauté
[Musique]
on a repoussé les meubles à l'extérieur
pour faire de la place au banc modeste
et inconfortable la cérémonie religieuse
dure 3 à 4 heures succession de champs
ils n'ont pratiquement pas changé depuis
200 ans de long prêche prononcé d'une
voix monocorde par des prêtres que rien
ne distingue des autres croyants et de
confessions publiques
[Musique]
et
à
jamais aucun témoin de l'extérieur des
guetteurs sont même posté derrière les
fenêtres pour éviter toute interférence
de ceux qui n'appartiennent pas à la
communauté
jf olic
ils n'ont rien changé à leur vie à leur
habitude à leurs cadres depuis plus de
200 ans
c'est en 1693 qu'un suisse jakob ammann
a fondé cette secte dana baptiste les
amish comme on les appelle depuis était
à l'origine des réformateurs de la
réforme persuadé que luther et calvin ne
s'était pas encore suffisamment éloigné
des pompes et des fastes de notre monde
d'ici bas
[Musique]
persécutée tout comme les autres
réformes et ils durent émigrés de leur
province d'origine
d'abord vers la france et la hollande
puis vers les états unis
les branches européennes des amis se
sont pratiquement éteinte maintenant en
revanche ils ont survécu aux états unis
intacte après plus de 200 ans
aujourd'hui encore chez les amish de
pennsylvanie ou de l'ohio quand on ne
s'appelle pas georges frêche c'est qu'on
s'appelle nappes ou schmocker
[Musique]
et
on s'appelle dans le schuss ou schmocker
représente d'ailleurs une différence
tout à fait secondaire le principe qui
régit chacun est celui de la séparation
du monde est le corollaire est celui de
la simplicité
moyennant quoi rien ne ressemble plus à
la vie d'un amish que la vie d'un autre
ami
tu vois
le rejet du monde extérieur se traduit
imanquablement par le rejet de toutes
ces facilités
les amish n'admettent ni l'électricité
ni la voiture automobile ni la radio ni
la télévision ni le téléphone
waouh ça
tout au plus accepté thil depuis
quelques temps et dans certaines
communautés seulement le gaz butane
considérés comme produits naturels
encore faut-il pour qu'une nouveauté
soit admise que le conseil des évêques
composé en général de 9 personnes de
neuf patriarche l'acceptent à
l'unanimité si un seul s'y opposent
la chose est rejetée ce qu'est le cas de
l'électricité depuis son invention
les vêtements comme le reste demeure
tels qu'ils étaient du temps de jacob
amman le noir est de rigueur pour tout
le monde
à peine souligné par le par mais le
verre pour les femmes en semaine
seulement l'absence de boutons et de
revers pour les vêtements d'homme
s'explique par la hantise traditionnelle
des anciens persécuteurs officiers et
soldats qui portaient cole et
brandebourg
les robes des femmes tiennent avec des
épingles ouverte
les enfants sont habillés comme les
parents
[Musique]
le souci de n'être pas lié au monde
extérieur fut ce par un fil conduit les
amish à utiliser encore ce système de
pompe archaïque amenant l'eau à un puits
qui se trouve à l'extérieur de la maison
l'eau courante c'est la facilité
donc c'est pour les autres ce qu'on
appelle les gens du monde
en théorie une famille vit sur une
propriété en pratique le nombre de
propriétés ne pouvons pas augmenter
indéfiniment n'est pas rare qu'un jeune
couple d'amis ch
après son mariage soit obligé de vivre
plusieurs années parfois plus longtemps
sur la propriété des parents ou des
beaux parents
les amish sont les meilleurs
agriculteurs des états unis ils
obtiennent uniquement par des méthodes
naturelles pas de tracteur pas d'engrais
chimiques peu de matériel agricole les
meilleurs rendements du pays la main
d'oeuvre est essentiellement familial
très qualifiés car spécialisée depuis
des siècles
ils tirent tous leurs revenus du travail
de la terre la culture du tabac rapporte
de l'argent
la culture du maïs de la nourriture pour
les hommes et pour les bêtes
avec un peu de grain quelques cultures
vivrières et un peu d'élevage
les amish qui sont passés maîtres dans
l'art des conservant bocal et des
viandes fumées produisent eux mêmes
près de 80 % de ce qu'il consomme
la femme clé de voûte de la cellule
familiale à sa place au chant tout comme
les enfants servant de son maître doit
mettre généralement plein de mansuétude
elle est directement responsable de tout
ce qui est provisions nourriture maison
entretien couture éducation des enfants
les travaux des champs c'est en prime
à leur corps défendant
car ils ne sont en rien responsables de
l'organisation touristique de la région
l'un des modèles du genre aux états unis
les amish sont devenus les bêtes
curieuses livret de mars à novembre
spécialement en fin de semaine à des
légions de citadins de banlieusards
avides de voir une vache pour la
première fois de leur existence ou de
contempler de près une femme qui fait sa
lessive avec ses mains ou plus
simplement une charrue ou une roue à
godets
[Musique]
mais
les gens du monde comme vous je pense
qu'ils sont en train de manquer le
bateau bien ils sont en train de
compromettre leur vie éternelle
comme je voulais déjà dit ils seront du
bon temps ici bas qu'ils auront tout à
leur goût ici bas et puis après qu'ils
auront à déplorer d'avoir perdu la vie
éternelle
cependant la religion amish n'est pas
missionnaire n'est pas exportable et
personne n'ira dire aux gens du monde ce
que cet ami julien de nous dire ignorant
d'ailleurs qu'il était filmé fut sa
distance c'est l'aspect rétrograde de
cette secte qui vit par elle et pour
elle le dos tourné au reste du monde et
donc pour qui la notion de prochain
s'arrête aux limites de la communauté
[Musique]
enfermé dans un cadre religieux très
stricte dans un style de vie en vase
clos dans une conception de la famille
très patriarcales et unitaire les amish
ont compris depuis toujours qu'il devait
conserver la haute main sur
l'instruction de leur enfant sous peine
de les perdre au sens social comme au
sens religieux
il mène depuis plus d'un siècle contre
les lois des états unis une bataille
épuisante pour essayer de conserver ce
privilège
le service religieux
la maison et l'école ce sont les trois
super tabou des amish les endroits où
les gens du monde ne peuvent pas
pénétrer et encore moins leurs caméras
[Musique]
statistiques à l'appui
bien peu de ces enfants quitteront leur
famille et le périmètre de la communauté
pratiquement aucun ne deviendra médecin
ni avocat un peu plus de 20000 amish
dans l'ohio un peu moins de 20000 en
pennsylvanie c'est un groupe qui se
maintient sans décliner grâce à une
moyenne d'environ huit enfants par
famille
et malgré les tentations de la société
qui l'entourent au demeurant le jeune
amish apprendra rapidement combien la
structure de la communauté le protège et
l'aide alors qu'à l'extérieur sévit la
loi de la jungle
les amish peu attachés aux biens de ce
monde ayant peu de besoins vivent
généralement à l'aise
[Musique]
il ya tout de même un point où les amish
sont obligés de rencontrer le monde
extérieur entièrement livrée aux travaux
des champs ils n'ont aucune technologie
et sont contraints d'acheter chez les
gens du monde certains outils certains
ustensiles certaines pièces de vêtements
chaussures par exemple ou de vendre
leurs produits aussi
m
[Musique]
les relations entre amis chez nos amis
ch sont excellentes
il n'y a pratiquement pas de problème
avec les amish qu'ils agissent des
jeunes ou des vieux et leurs impôts ils
sont inscrits sur la liste électorale
il pense surtout que doivent s'occuper
d'eux mêmes ils ont leur propre système
de sécurité sociale quand il ya un
incendie
quand une grange est détruite par le feu
toute la communauté des barques et il
faut tout ce qu'il faut au tour mettre
debout et en état et c'est l'un des
spectacles les plus extraordinaires de
la vie amish assez rares il est vrai car
les amis je partage avec leurs
compatriotes américains au moins un
point
la hantise du ce et les incendies de
grange sont rares toujours est il que la
solidarité prend ici un sens absolu car
toute la communauté participe à la
reconstruction non seulement en main
d'oeuvre
mais même en argent si c'est nécessaire
la seule punition réel imposé à une amie
ch
exclu du groupe pour en avoir
transgressé les lois internes et
précisément l'interdiction d'aider les
autres quant aux lois civiles
ils les ignorent
le marché aux chevaux et hebdomadaires
amis chaînon amish ils sont mêlés en
toute fraternité paysanne et pour que
les choses soient plus simples et plus
nettes
l'assesseur du commissaire priseur est
un ami c'est là l'un des rares pont jeté
entre la communauté fondée naguère par
jacob amman et les gens du monde dont
elle s'était détourné par souci de
préserver la vie éternelle
[Musique]
la communauté amish a réussi à se
préserver plus de 200 ans au prix de
plusieurs émigration lé nouveau menacé
aujourd'hui d'abord parle et aux
industriels économiques et sociales qui
cherchent à la broyé ensuite par les
lois scolaires qui tendront de plus en
plus à la priver d'un des piliers de sa
construction survivra-t-elle à la fin de
ce siècle
rien n'est moins sûr
[Musique]
e